you guys have had several kissing scenes
scenes where you kiss each other yes and
I'm just curious is Ashton a good kisser
when you guys kiss what's the experience
for you guys I'm gonna say oh yeah he
has nothing to be ashamed of
right yeah let me tell you it was a
little weird because we had thank you we
had won the first season and then we got
married in the last season so we had a
few yeah more deep more deeply intimate
ones yes exactly
which is you know it takes some getting
used to yeah what was the experience
like for you I should be kissing you
know a guy John's my second male kiss on
screen my first one was in dude where's
my car
yes and uh you know here's the thing if
you want to know if you're not gay
kiss a dude because if you feel nothing
you know and like while John's wonderful
human there was nothing
oh right there was nothing and it's
weird cause he had a little stubble
right and now I understand the issue
with this double you yeah okay because
it's a little scratchy and itchy that's
what I'm saying right here on it yeah
yeah all kinda just hurt you now John
cuz you clearly did feel something
this is a horrible way to find out see
your eyes tearing out for a second you
cuts the side of the chair that is
awkward yeah - that's the way it was you
know whatever didn't mean anything by
the show's over
whatever Sherrod its charade Oh know
what when you're kissing another fella
yeah
[Applause]
you